you are a Jewish gentleman you are a
Jewish man and are you did you have a
are you going to have a bris a going to
have one and nobody has one later maybe
they do know we had one early on but not
a bris meaning the traditional and
ritualistic religio so a fair but
medically although it was a question
before but finally we decided upon
getting that you know what a bris does
you know what it is I think everybody
removal of it's a circumcision the
foreskin is removed yes exactly exactly
so the doctor window yeah our lovely
doctor Randy Harris who used to play for
the Mets good plug before really I don't
know yeah no I mean I but he became a
then he became yeah a doctor so he said
you know this is not in any way
religious but I think it's a good idea I
do it I do it good you can watch if you
want it's not so not so nice but anyway
he he did it he says but I don't say the
traditional blessing I sing take me out
to the ballgame
as I'm doing and if you want to join in
and we did you guys sang taking out to
the ballgame and then when he was done
with that it was just you know well it's
not it's not what you think have you
ever seen it they don't use a deli
slicer yeah I know they they you said
sorry did you just did you do it did you
do it did you do it to your not children
oh you have you have good you have a boy
and a girl that's right and you didn't
do it you're no answer
my son is uncircumcised I mean it
everybody at school my son's
uncircumcised
I didn't it's really more his
information to give out but I guess I
screwed up sorry huh
so yeah so you must have researched it
and it's because of the natural way yes
yes you want him to look like dad no no
I glad this is going this way now I'm
circumcised but I don't you know I mean
I imagine so yeah yes I mean you know I
mean we've done so obviously a Jew that
no no I mean I'm circumcised because I
was born in the time when it was just
there was no question about a standard
in this cult yeah yeah but with with my
son I mean as I told the doctor I I said
he was born perfect why change him what
I'm saying is you've mutilated your
child well I know the argument I listen
I I think it's probably you're probably
right yeah yeah yeah you know what is no
wrong in time with my cut one it's been
fine you know I mean it's not like it
robbed me of anything either okay
I know it screw the commercials we need
to talk more about my dick
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
question seven in the car sad about
Andy's daddy is thought out much more
than you would ever know
ah you're still here god I love you I
love you good